this new bill in America's Top Hat up in
Canada that would in certain areas
outlaw
transphobia firstly it enables the
Attorney General to create a 2s LGBT Qi
plus Community safety zone to prohibit
within a hundred meters of the property
any homophobic transphobic Act of
intimidation threat offensive threats
offensive remarks protest disturbance
and distribution of hate propaganda
within the meaning of the criminal code
it also comes with it a penalty of
twenty five thousand dollars if
prosecuted successfully if you're in one
of the anti-free speech zones if you're
in one of forget even anti-free speech
if you're in one of the transgender
protection zones which I'm sure they're
going to make the whole country
and you say
women are real
and men are not them you'd be fine
twenty five thousand dollars
according to this bill